Let's talk about how to infer denial
of service activity using a technique called backscatter.
The idea behind backscatter is that when
an attacker spoofs a source IP address, say
on a TCP SYN flood attack, that the replies to that initial TCP SYN from the
victim will go to the location of the source IP address. This replies to
forged attack messages are called" backscatter". Now
the interesting thing about backscatter is that if
we can assume that the source IP addresses
are selected by the attacker at random, and
we could set up a portion of the network where we could monitor this back
scatter traffic, coming back as SYN-ACK replies to
forged source IP addresses. If we assume that
these source IP addresses are picked uniformly at random, then the amount of
traffic that we see as back scatter. Represents exactly a fraction that's
proportional to the size of the overall attack. So for example, if we monitor N
IP addresses and we see M attack packets, then we expect
to see here N over two to the 32 of the total
back scatter packets and hence of the total attack rate. If we want to compute
the total attack rate, we simply invert this fraction. So for
example, in this case, if our telescope were a slash eight, or two
to the 24th IP addresses, we would simply multiply our observed
attack rate x by two to the 32 divided
by two to the 24 or 255.